In this challenge episode
we’re gonna attempt the
20 candle extinguishing shot
Team up with the world’s
best trampoliners
and more...
Let’s get into it!
First one
to miss the cup
loses...
200 cups
Don't miss the shot!
You lost before it even started!
It shouldn't be that hard!
What if you lose this?
We have to come up with the punishment
Otto’s smash to the back!
We know it comes hard!
Don't miss the ball!
Was that a good strategy?
No it wasn't...
It almost came back!
Don't worry guys
I got your back!
He’s doing a warm up already
It went into the cup!
It fell!
I think you can clearly see
the ball
is not in the cup!
Thank you very much!
Hey what racket are you using?
One warm up!
What?!
Yeah that hurts!
Sorry Miikka
A genuine sorry from Otto!
Next, we're going to blow out
as many candles as possible
in one single shot
First one!
I heard that you tried to blow out
three candles
but it never happened
We tried it four different days
Or something
To get the triple candle
but never got it
But I have to say
this is a bit easier
We’re gonna do at least 20 today
It came back alive!
It's very convenient
because you don't have to put it back
I can't believe that it worked!
This is the first viral trick
that we ever did!
This is the thing where it started for us!
that went viral
Like, completely viral!
Please show us six!
Six seemed to be too easy...
We're going straight to ten!
I wonder how far we can take this?
At least 20
That's the new record!
I think let's go to 20!
Yeah I think so too
There is no way this is happening...
It will happen!
We're jumping from 10 to 20
Normal day!
It's nine only
Is that a new record?
It's 11!
A new world record
11!
But we're not happy with that
No we're not having that...
It’s a new record Emil!
It’s 12!
We got it!
I guess 12 is the new world record
Hit the hardest that you can!
I don't like that one
How many do you want?
Well as many as you can fit there
Maximum speed forehand!
I feel like I didn't even move my hands
The final weight of the puzzle
53 lbs added weight!
I’m hitting as hard as I can!
I felt like I was in a
slow motion movie all the time
Now it'll be super interesting
to see him play without the weights!
I've never seen him move like that!
I think we can make that work
That was incredible!
Smooth!
It was in!
That was nice!
First try!
That was a hard return!
That’s insane!
It's scarily close to the bar!
We've done the backflip shot
so now we're going to do the double backflip!
We’re gonna get this!
That's incredible!
It actually came on the table!
Was it in?
It was in!
It actually went on my side!
That’s talent
Shall we call it a day?
From out of nowhere!
That is evidence!